[Music]
um
okay
all right
welcome
up
okay
um
the the um eric has classified the dog
as menacing
um
and the the primary effect of that is
that storm must be muzzled when in
public so we have not infringed in this
case we've just issued the
classification
is that clear enough or do you want more
um do you like more detail
oh i suppose the final the final step of
the final option is prosecution
which is where we would actually take
the dog owner to to prosecute criminally
which we have not done either
thank you um
i don't know whether it's appropriate a
question to you or when um the owners
come forward but i see there's a
note of
the animals required to be the dogs
required to be de-sexed under the
medicine classification
as well as muscle munchies in public i
was going to ask is she spayed or is she
she
spayed
yeah it wasn't clear from here so i
thought i would
would ask that thank you
um
so
no other questions well thank you thank
you for your report
um
and i
i move that um
we've got two recommendations here to
receive the report
uh oh no we can leave that till the end
actually that's the decision
forget that that's good thank you very
much
um item five is um
the report from eric de boer and a
management officer so i invite you up
here to speak to your report
now to you thank you good afternoon
everyone um my name is eric dubois um
i'm an animal management officer with
the waimak district council
warranted under
section 11 of the dog control act 96
been in the role for eight years
um
on friday the 15th of october
i was on duty
working from the office when we received
a call from customer services to advise
that mr weaver was at the counter
to report an incident that um had taken
place earlier that morning
which resulted in him being bitten
so um
i went down and met with mr weaver to
take his statement um
are you happy to take the statement as
read
yes
yeah thank you
um
then i've arranged for him to send me
photographs of the injury
the next day because he'd already been
to the doctor and been bandaged up so
and also the location of it was a bit
awkward to try and photograph
so after taking the statement
i went back to find out
the dog details and then visited the
property and met with
jared and his partner jesse
introduced myself and for the reason i
was there and then um
[Music]
we arranged to meet the dog to see what
she was like with myself as a stranger
[Music]
just to assess if she's you know
threatening towards people
or if it was just dogs and it appears
that it's just dogs that she has an
aversion to so
i believe that
she doesn't pose an immediate threat to
people um
it's not going to go out of the way to
do that and that's why i've opted for
menacing
um
because i don't
class here as dangerous to the public
um just a menace towards other dogs
um
i left the property and advised that
we'd be in touch and due course with um
the course of action that we would take
um i got the photos from mr weaver um
have you you've got copies of those yeah
yeah thank you and uh
the report from the doctor
so um
the the photos show clearly that it is a
dog bite that he's sustained so i'm
happy that that's what's happened
um
[Music]
i then formally classified storm as
menacing on the 20th of october
so obviously it's not a decision we
take lightly we
take quite a bit of
consideration and thought as it's quite
a big deal obviously for the dog owner
so we discuss that within the team
you know we've all got a lot of
experience
run through the scenario and then
make a call from there what we think is
appropriate course of action um
obviously our job is to keep the
community safe and we felt that
classifying as menacing was appropriate
in this case
thank you
any questions
that's redmond
uh
thank you eric
in
terms going forward
a dog needs to be under effect of
control
when in a public space is that correct
that's correct
if if storm in this case you've
indicated isn't a threat to
people
as such but
could be a threat to other animals
that's right
if the dog is on a lead in a public
place
how can it be a threat to other animals
if it's unmuzzled
if it's under effective control then
obviously it's not going to be an issue
but it's the trying to mitigate
the chance of it happening again and all
it's going to take is for the lead to
slip out of your hand or
lose control or slip and let go of the
lead
and then it still doesn't achieve
anything whereas a muzzle will prevent
any further harm
even if she got away
in the circumstances as we know them on
this occasion
if the dog was classified as menacing
would that have had any
different outcome
from what occurred
um
possibly not
still would have
escaped i think
all right thanks very much
any questions
no
okay
um just
generally between um and following the
line of
counselor redmond
there's no
review of the public muzzling
requirement if
menacing is confirmed
i note that the dog is now
being well proposed to be taken to
obedience training
is there any
and it's a young dog so my question
would be is there any review period or
in fact
it stays to be muzzled in public no
once a dog is classified as menacing
yeah and you uphold the decision it
would stay with the dog for life
okay
thank you for that
and council meetings
just following on from from
counselors you know
stuart's question
is there any mechanism for us to have
this dog undergo the training that it's
doing
and then
be
re-adjudicated i guess reclassified or
is it just
a case of now or never
from from past experience it's either
now or never um
it would be something i would need to
confer with
my
superiors about really
i'm not aware of the training that's
going on so
i've got a leader here from our dog
trainer can i should i bring that up now
beautiful thank you
good afternoon um
first of all
i'd like to thank you all for your time
today um
and we'd like to take this opportunity
to apologize to brian unfortunately
can't be here
for what has happened
it's not that nature to not be able to
apologize especially with how upsetting
this situation has been for my partner
jessie and myself um
we've taken full responsibility and we
believe we're taking the right steps to
making sure a situation like this never
happens again
um
we believe we felt we had to object as
we never saw evidence of a bite until
late last week so it's very hard for us
to
comprehend this without seeing evidence
ourselves
jesse cannot fully recall what happened
between the dogs that day
and
if the guy didn't notice till he got
home how are we certain that it was our
dog and not their dog
um
storm has never shown any signs of
aggression towards any dog or person she
loves playing and is very socialized we
take both dogs to the dog park oh sorry
we have two dogs um we take both our
dogs to the dog park every weekend
and this is why it's been a massive
shock to us i've never seen
like this so
um due to what has happened we've made
contact with some dog trainers that
afternoon
and we got booked in with janice from
tevra dog training uh the following
weekend we've taken her to one-on-one
training and have since carried on with
group classes which is going really well
we bought a muzzle instantly as it was
the right thing to do
and we have also padlocked our gates as
an extra precaution
oh yeah
okay
uh we will carry on muzzling when out in
public and carry on training her for as
long as we need
the hardest part for us is for her to be
classified menacing for her whole life
which you guys obviously understand that
um with your questions earlier um is
there an opportunity to revisit this if
it is upheld
essentially like a prisoner doing time
you know they eventually get released
and
live a somewhat normal life again you
know can we revisit this down the line
um we got storm
and our other dog to enjoy our life and
have fun we like to take them places
like the river play ball and stick
for them
to have fun also
knowing that we will never be able to do
this again is really hard to say the
least
obviously she can't pick up a ball or a
stick at the moment um
as we have said we believe we've done
everything possible taking all the right
steps to resolve this issue
um once again we apologize for this
incident
that has happened uh sorry accident has
happened
and um i have a statement here from gc i
don't know if you guys have got
want to hear that or
yep
um
on friday the 15th the internal garage
door was left open while putting stuff
in the car jesse thought the two dogs
were out eating breakfast when she saw
shh
sorry
when she saw storms she passed her
running towards the other dog
she could have been running to say hello
but we understand it is not okay for any
dog to do this
jesse's knee gave way which has slowed
her down she grabbed her collar and fell
to the ground
crying storm then just sat next to her
no barking growling or trying to lunge
she apologized multiple times but just
got yelled at saying your dog is so
aggressive that's all that was said
before he walked off to talk to a guy
down the road
not being able to move and get up
and for it to be left like that has been
extremely hard for jesse
um
we got sent his medical bill
which said there was an abrasion
on it we paid this instantly and also
asked to call and apologize which was
declined
uh thanks jared and jason for coming
along
um
i was quite impressed by reading
your version of events
and the responsible
attitude you've shown
how long have you owned a storm
uh two years now well just about two
years yeah so you've had the dog since
it was a puppy yeah yeah we got her as a
puppy
and when you take it to a dog park does
it show any interest in other dogs
yeah definitely she loves to play with
them but um
very you know she doesn't she doesn't
show any aggression or anything like
that yeah
and
have there been any other incidents at
any stage where the dog has misbehaved
or
played over aggressively with other
animals i guess like any puppy he
understands that sometimes things go far
and that's how they learn but um nothing
that's excessive like this no
and you've provided us with a letter
yep
are you following up the training and
recommendations yes yeah we go to
training every sunday now well when it's
booked on we've been going for a month
or so now yeah so um yeah we're seeing
good results in her recall and things
like that so um yeah she's definitely
getting better
i think these dogs are quite intelligent
yeah definitely my cocker spaniel could
bear um some training i think but
you're finding the training worthwhile
and you're getting benefits from
definitely yeah
right thank you
hi jared and jesse
i can understand that this is quite a
traumatic um thing for a dog owner to to
go through
having been a dog person all my life
um
so you've had this you've had storms
since she was a pup did you undergo any
puppy training with her at all
i know not actually because it was
covered when she was quite a bit younger
so
and then i suppose we may have been a
bit lazy and the times between but um
yeah
so have you had big dogs before like
this uh in our families yeah yeah so my
parents have got a big dog and she's his
parents also got a big dog
because i mean that is one thing that
when it comes to dogs big dogs can never
be forgiven for the transgressions that
smaller dogs get away with so it's
always imperative that you really take
that
really seriously and make sure that your
dogs don't
grow up to to get out of hand
um
so it it sounds to me like this as a
case of
territorial aggression has she ever
shown territorial aggression before with
other animals or things you know looking
out the window seeing dogs or
birds or whatever you know looking out
the window kind of thing
um i suppose she chases birds in the
backyard
yeah yeah apart from that no not that i
can think of nothing
and the the training that you've got i i
understand tevra is um
yeah i
do know of the the company they're um
quite well known so you and you are
getting good results with that and um
how long are you do you intend
oh as long as possible yes we're just
gonna keep doing it because it's yeah
it's making such a difference she's like
a different dog almost
um and but what is your other dog
he's a collie
shepherd cross thingy yeah
so similar right
we got him as a rescue dog so he's we
got him
maybe one year ago so and he's
we think he's about four maybe something
like that so he's already well trained
and um yeah
okay
thank you
um
have you seen the photos of mr weaver's
leg in the agenda
yes we saw them uh was it thursday or
friday
last week yeah so um that was
why we kind of thought well we need to
object this because we haven't seen any
evidence as such
yeah
it's
definitely more than an abrasion
i mean you can see the two
entry points um of the bite i was i was
also going to ask you about your other
dog
um
uh is it muted yes yeah we are muted
right and i note that you say
in your statement to us um she's
generally a good dog
but can get a bit unruly um while
playing with other dogs
what what does she what does she do i
mean
this is um an obedience issue if jessie
was obviously calling her back and she
failed to come back
when she was called
i mean when you say she gets a bit
unruly
what does that mean
she's vocal which plays so it can sound
um it can sound like she is
maybe being aggressive but um she is a
vocal doll so she
does sort of so it's just vocalization
yeah that's right yeah i guess just a
wee bit yeah
and
have you had instances before when you
call her and she doesn't come back
yes
and hopefully the training will oh yeah
to that we're noticing it already we
have a long rope that we can let her off
on now and call her and she comes
straight back and yeah we're rewarding
our treats and that so yeah
okay
thank you
um
any further
any further questions i'm councillor
redmond
thanks jared
do you accept that storm caused the
injuries to mr weaver
um i accept that she
yeah i suppose she did in a way yeah
because she ran across the road and
didn't listen but um yeah it's just very
hard for us to believe that
she was the one that put him with her
yeah i don't know it's kind of hard to
explain if you know what i mean um
yeah if he got in between the two of
them
yeah
yeah i suppose she didn't yes
and as a creek your property is fully
fenced yes yep but on this occasion the
dog storm got out through the garage
is there anything you can do to prevent
that occurring again
uh we've made a point to put the dogs
outside every time we go out to the
garage now so they're out in the
backyard and doors are all closed so
they can't can't escape it
okay
okay thank you
i've just
looked at the statement from mr weaver
and
he says that um
the dog his dog was i mean you've said
that you accept that that storm caused
the injuries because he talks about um
his old dog being on her back um when
your dog um
sort of launched well
came across the road
um to her
um have you have you read this comment
yeah okay and have you any anything else
to
bring up after seeing this it's pretty
hard for me to um say comment because i
wasn't there and obviously jesse was
slow to get there because in there so
she's
um acknowledged that this
um
that the dog the old dog was on its back
and i don't actually know if i've seen
that but i don't recall oh okay yeah
this is
this is mr weaver's response to
your report that's in the agenda you
haven't seen that no
oh well i wonder if they could um
because this is
we're taking this because mr weave is
unable to attend and he's responded to
rules
okay
we will just
it will just take a short break while um
well jared and jesse heather have a read
thank you
resume is there anything you'd like to
to
tell us or add after reading that
i guess for me just to be recalling
everything it's quite hard but yes i
don't think
i remember when i went to grad storm's
collar that the other dog's teeth were
there like just makes like oh i have to
watch out for my hand but i don't recall
it being on the ground on its back
but that's just yeah the whole situation
is just such a blur now
yeah
from experience i know
how these things work or don't work and
yes it's um it's fairly intense and
recall is um
always all over the show but
all right um well thank you for that um
i
don't know i think probably now
so we we've got mr weaver's um
and then we've got his um
i've got yeah we've got
this so we'll we'll table that and
accept it this
i guess is there any points that we need
to
consider with um
with that evidence
but difficult thing is not here
all right
um councilwoman
i guess this all happened very quickly
do you see have you any idea
how long the whole incident
the
occurred it would have been saw a shoot
pass me i like try to run but my knee
snapped straight away so that maybe took
a little bit longer to see it across the
road and i would have grabbed your
collar
i don't remember wrestling her off
because i was like i don't think i would
have been able to just grabbed a collar
and fell to the ground and he stood
there and said some things and then just
walked off so maybe
two minutes max
i just was yeah
yeah
thank you
all right um at this point i think we'll
take a short adjournment um and then
um i'll be quite keen to have some
advice from tracy and eric
along the lines of
just what options are available
and
then we can work through the
deliberation so thank you too i know
it's
traumatic um to have experienced that
with your dog but also probably
traumatic to come and tell us about it
now
but thank you very much appreciate um
your frankness um and certainly that um
the dog is now in training is a great
outcome so well done
all right so we'll just take a small
what do we now
for say i'm back in at 2 15
gives us 10 minutes
how's that
[Music]
okay so just to clarify um
um
[Music]
do
uh
[Music]
me
wow
um
[Music]
thank you
so
[Music]
you